okay so i had kind of a crazy afternoon
the other day my producing partner amber
25 years we've been together she's right
over there
go emmer so we helped out a dog that had
been involved in a hit and run
and what happened was okay so our friend
preeca starts crying and screaming and
we're like what's going on
and so he tells us that he just saw a
dog get hit by a car so amber and i
ran across the street to help and it was
just a very jarring experience but it
was an amazing
reminder of how sometimes strangers can
come together for help
there was a bunch of us crowded around
the dog and then eventually i got the
dog on the leash
and stayed with it and then i was like
scared to touch it because i wanted to
pet the head and i was like you've just
been in an accident and it was just
it was just a wild experience but i
tried to give calm and good energy to
the dog
and everyone was just trying to do their
best and look even if paparazzi pitched
in and took
photos this is a community experience
and then we put the dog in ember's car
and took it to the vet and i'm happy to
tell you
that the dog is going to be okay
all right our vfs you guys look amazing
i'm calling for a colleen and steve
are you there
hi guys we love you we love drew's nudes
we love the intro
we love your show you guys do i'm so
thrilled the whole news crew and i
eric and sammy the whole team we love uh
sound effects we have a cat screeching
in there and everything so
thank you and can you know what you're
welcome in honor of you guys
i'm gonna kick off drew's news and
dedicate it to you today
let's do it it's time for drew's news
sir ma'am guy ma'am
i asked you a question
[Music]
it's drew's news
all right let's see what made the papers
okay so this is kind of a weird story
you know the show the mask
singer it's so fun
apparently people on the internet are
convinced i'm the popcorn
guys i'm totally not the popcorn i
promise however
i am legally forbidden from commenting
on whether or not i am the crocodile and
i'm also not saying anything about that
son
so stop asking
up next when i read this story with the
news crew i thought yeah
this all tracks check this out the wall
street journal yesterday asked
is the broad dead they're reporting that
bra
purchases are down and i feel for the
bra companies i certainly don't want
them to be in any trouble
but people are working from home and
they're going more loosey-goosey
you know i can only speak for myself on
this one i don't think there's anything
more medieval
than the bra i hate it kill it live that
loosely goosey life
hashtag live loosey-goosey
moving on if you ever thought oh man
i wish there was a candy that tasted
like meat
well get ready for this it's food news
sammy soles on the sound effects all
right brock's
announced its newest seasonal treat
turkey dinner candy corn brox has given
us the thanksgiving dinner no one really
asked for
in every bag there's flavors like
cranberry sauce green beans stuffing
my favorite can't get enough of it and
roast turkey
okay so i've got my tiny little
thanksgiving right here
vffs who's ready to feast with me jason
hi drew hi jason
hello you ready to try this
i'm doing it i've got my bag i think i
have a turkey
here it goes what color are you doing
all right i go for
down the hatch it's the yellow it's the
yellow top brown bottom
oh yeah that's turkey
i think i got like pumpkin pie because
mine's really sweet and it's actually
really good
well you i i'm not saying this is bad
but
definitely meaty
[Applause]
jason i couldn't want to be doing this
with anybody else more you are so
awesome
thank you so much for diving into this
surprisingly mine was delicious so
brock's call me
thanks jason all right it's no secret i
am
an animal lover why that's why this next
story caught my
eye it's been said that when your cat
stares at you really intensely and then
slowly blinks
it's giving you a cat kiss pop sugar has
consulted with
vets who say it's true when a cat stares
at you
it's often because she's trying to
connect and show affection so if she
blinks
blink right back still got some pumpkin
pie
right here look these are my cats peach
and lucky
oh they're loving me so hard right now
lucky's even given me the one-eyed wink
and by the way
the reason i love this story is because
i have
a lot of animals okay i have a yellow
parrot a bearded dragon
two dogs i have chickens and i have to
say
something in all sincerity they do
wink at you and they do not have
the power of voice and i do think it's
how they're saying
like they're happy they're content
they're throwing you
you know the bone of gratitude and just
saying i love you so
right back at you guys
okay time for a beauty junkie alert
[Applause]
all right these products that have just
helped hit the shelves
are good for the environment and your
daily beauty routine
pumpkin pie marie claire brock's
um marie claire has a list of a
solid sham oh sorry these are bar
shampoos and conditioners
and they can replace all of those
plastic bottles
i definitely am very excited to speak
about all the alternatives paper
and aluminum and you know just glass
different resources
but these have eradicated all of it and
it's so much better for the environment
so check it out lather rinse save the
planet repeat